the idea of a mayor of london has been
legendary for the 600 years since dick
whittington and his
cat although in modern times the 9
million
citizens of greater london have only had
an elected mayor since the year 2000.
ken boris and sadiq the only three
mayors london's had so far
in a role created by prime minister tony
blair
i would i think i was the luckiest
because when i became mayor in 2000 we
had a labor government
i got billions of pounds out of them i
mean huge investment in improving our
transport
infrastructure i bought 8 000 new buses
poor old city i can't get loads of money
out boris johnson
this may after a delay in extension for
covid
voters are choosing a mayor again the
incumbent labour sadiq khan a former mp
and ministers main
challengers are the conservative sean
bailey
who has no parliamentary experience and
the co-leader of the green
sean berry the mayor of london has
responsibility for
transport policing and some
infrastructure
but except for what can be raised from
the council tax and
fares they're dependent on central
government for funding
that's pretty limited compared to
counterparts
such as the mayor of new york city but
that's left plenty of room for
eye-catching initiatives such as what
became known
as boris bikes
johnson's director for the environment
pioneered many of the mayor's
transport initiatives we saw a fantastic
opportunities actually adam it was
may 2008 sun was shining the world looks
a good
great place we had lots of ideas what we
wanted to do but we were faced with a
financial crisis
very a few months after coming in which
impacted every part of london but
particularly london politics london
boroughs the budgets the challenges
how we could invest even the government
working with a labour government at that
point
then a coalition government and then a
conservative government it meant the
mayor has to be
both a political leader a leader of the
city someone who
everyone looks to to find the solutions
of what's going on
in this big place that is a is actually
something that represents a global
position for this country johnson was
lucky in what he inherited from his
predecessor
including the idea of the bikes and most
notably
the london 2012 olympics the result of
fierce lobbying
by blair livingston and the late tessa
jowl
of course but without his eight years in
city hall
it's unlikely johnson would have become
conservative leader
let alone prime minister khan says he
has nothing to thank johnson
for as mayor or as prime minister when i
became mayor
i inherited a tfl which had an
additional seven billion pounds of debt
which he'd borrowed
and paying back the interest on his debt
they've given a blank check to the
privatized
trade up companies for 18 months nothing
against that but they're attaching
draconian
strings to tfl and the problem with them
doing that is tfl is integral
to london businesses doing well london
businesses are integral
to the country doing well and the prime
minister's in danger of cutting his nose
despite his face
so does he have any plans to copy
johnson and use london
as a springboard to number 10. no i
think i've got the best job in uh
politics and after seeing the mess boris
johnson's making i think i'm better off
in city hall
dick whittington and his cat were
problem solvers dealing with the rat
problem
and rebuilding the city with the riches
they earned
today mayors face the practical problems
of making london better
while central government blows hot and
cold
what matters to me most is that london
gets better
because i'm i i've always i've lived in
london for 75 years
my kids are living in it i want them to
have a good world so
and i do think this is just about the
best city in the world
this is the most diverse the most
tolerant
the new job of mayor of london comes of
age this year
but so far this century has yet to
produce a match for dick whittington
adam sky news london